my name is Carolina I'm an AI consultant
at the German climate Computing Center
and I will present today something we
learned when we try to bridge Earth
system models with python
so let me set the scene here a bit
a nerve system model describes the full
Globe the atmosphere we land and the
ocean discretized on a grid and it's
typically used for climate projections
and for weather forecasts and there is
an ongoing research effort to describe
certain processes that happen within the
Atmosphere by Machine learning
components but can be more flexible more
accurate than what you would have in a
typical Earth System model
and now we come to the problem vrf
substance model itself is written in
Fortran mainly for performance reasons
and also for legacy reasons
on the other side we have machine
learning components are developed in
Python so in our case in pi torch but
they universally use python apis
so what we do not want to do certainly
is to re-implement machine learning
modules in Fortran because we love
python right
and what we also do not want to do is to
re-implement the Earth System model in
in Python the other way around
um because that would just take a
ridiculous amount of time
so we need to bridge Fortran and Python
and you may know that python is not
really a language that likes to be
embedded very much
but we can use a c4n function interface
short cffi it's a very convenient
library but lets you export the API of
your choice to any c application but you
can use then again for example in your
Fortran code or other C based code bases
so we will use the machine learning code
as an external component inside of
Fortran
and we have two requirements for our
Bridge it should be flexible and it
should be performant so we do not want
to waste a lot of computational
resources by playing around with python
inside of this very much tuned portrait
model
so this is how it looks like inside of
your supercomputer
we have
um the BSM code running on four nodes
here so for computational nodes in
parallel in reality these are much more
notes but just for Simplicity I drew 4
here
and co-located with each of these
Fortran processors there should be a
python code that is executed but
exchanges data with Fortran process we
have a ram
so what is happening here we go with
standard way to include external program
components in any compiled code we
compile python code into a dynamic
library and Link it to the Fortran
executable
this is done very conveniently by the
cffi library so we write pure python
code and have to write only very few
lines of additional code so we can use
the cffi routines to generate our
Dynamic Library
at a Portland runtime python has been
initialized in the Frozen python code
from the dynamic library is executed
on a technical level the arrays that
have been allocated in Fortran are read
from the buffer in Python service is
kind of a fast way of exchanging data
between Fortran and python
so we have a little demo case where we
replace a single Fortran function with a
corresponding function but in Python and
we were just interested so is it
flexible is it fast and is it performant
um as I already mentioned PF System
model is running in parallel so we tried
out for different numbers of processors
that we have System model occupies how
performant is our python solution
and what we see here is that we use a
small number of parallel processes for
example 32
using cffi the blue dots compared to
using pure Fortran the red dots adds a
increase of about 10 times
so this is uh kind of to be expected
because we have additional data exchange
and also because python is typically
slower than portrait
but if we scale to a higher number of
parallel processes for example 2048
parallel processes on the Fortran side
we observe that the cffi really takes up
almost a factor of 100 more time than
initially so this is going to be a
problem if we want to scale this
solution across many different nodes
unfortunately at this point in time I
cannot yet tell you the the issue of
this problem and how to solve it we are
still ongoing here further investigation
um I did not find a lot of stuff on this
anywhere in documentations and online so
I appreciate any discussion on that
so main takeaways um from this lightning
talk is that you can use the C for in
function interface to embed python code
it is not scary I found it scary at
first but it really is not it's very
much doable
this approach is flexible so you can
easily replace with trained networks you
can easily adapt the python code and you
do not need to have a lot of knowledge
of fortron so this is usable also for
the modern data data scientist who's
trained more in Python and not in other
languages
um it's not yet as performant as we
would like to add so
um the overhead seems reasonable at
first but there's the scaling issue when
we go to highly parallel processes
that's it from my side if you want to
stay in touch here is my email address
and my LinkedIn and happy for any
discussion over on Discord